[Music]
it was the hot
summer of 2019 i was at the khan
film festival attending a world premiere
and leonardo dicaprio was clapping for
me
yes i know well not just for me
as you may know leonardo dicaprio is a
u.n messenger for peace
with a special focus on climate change
his project at khan was a new
documentary
on global warming ice on fire
instead of the usual doom and gloom you
might expect
his documentary took a new approach
it showcased the work of real scientists
measuring co2 emissions in hawaii
researchers monitoring methane leaks in
alaska
and engineers inventing technologies
that fight climate change
and i was one of those engineers
the technology i helped create and
develop
called direct air capture was featured
in leonardo's documentary
and yes i called him leonardo we're
close
while i'm not here to promote ice on
fire you should probably still check it
out
rather i'm here to talk to you about
what i expect i will be doing for my
entire life
i'm here to talk to you about the good
the bad
and the absolute necessity of direct air
capture
as the name suggests director capture
uses machines
to capture carbon dioxide or co2
from the air these machines use air
which contain 0.04 percent co2
and deliver 100 concentrated co2
the pure co2 can be used as a chemical
building block
for other materials like plastics or
synthetic fuels
but the vast majority of it must be
stored underground for good
how do these machines work there are
several technologies out there
but they all have chemistry at their
core and they all have the same goal
to capture and remove carbon dioxide
from the air
but let's look at it step by step and i
am an engineer so i will be going into
all the gory details
in a first step big fans bring air in
contact with the filter
that you can imagine as a sponge
the filter continuously and selectively
takes up co2 from the air until the
sponge is saturated
in a second step the co2
is unloaded from the filter either using
heat
or pressure this is where we squeeze the
sponge
so that we can use it again once free of
co2
the filter can be ready for another
loading and unloading cycle
the final result is pure co2
from the air and better yet
atmospheric air would reduce co2
concentrations
hope you're still with me and that you
have a good idea of how this all works
now you might be wondering well there's
a lot of
air out there and at only 0.04
co2 well director capture
sounds like looking for a needle in a
haystack
why bother to understand
why we need to look at the current state
of climate change
and here the doom and gloom are frankly
justified the world
has emitted so much co2 that most
climate models
show that global warming cannot be kept
to the original
1.5 degree temperature limit
the good news there are current efforts
underway
to decarbonize the economy electric cars
solar panels windmills these will help
reduce
the amount of co2 we put into the
atmosphere
the bad news there is no off
switch we cannot stop emissions tomorrow
even if we wanted to this can only be
a gradual process
so we need director capture
and this is where director capture comes
into play
to remove historic legacy emissions
and to help our increasing efforts of
decarbonization
we need director capture with co2
storage
underground so that all the excess co2
from the atmosphere
is stored away for good
i want to acknowledge as for some of you
putting co2 back underground sounds like
a worrying prospect
people ask me is there space underground
is it safe will the co2 just leak back
out
that's because we mostly imagined earth
as a solid ball
dense and compact but that's not the
case
we know there is space for the co2
underground because that's where it came
from
in the first place from natural gas
oil and coal that we've mined and burned
so what are the benefits of director
capture what does this do for us
first we can control how many machines
we build
and how fast we build them second their
efficiency
and their performance can be measured
and we can easily track and certify
how much co2 we've removed this
technology
gives us control over our climate change
mitigation strategy
but why do we need director capture if
we have trees
and other natural solutions and here
it's not an either or we need both
we need as many large forests as
possible
to capture co2 and keep it in the carbon
natural cycle
carbon natural cycle already relies on
soils
forests and the oceans to keep co2 out
of the atmosphere
but that's not enough forest cannot be
large enough
to keep all the co2 all the excess co2
that we have
worse even is that climate change and
human behavior affect forests
and today we are losing more trees than
we're adding
so we need director capture something
that even the critics of this technology
can acknowledge and what do the critics
say
some say co2 removal or technological
carbon removal
should be our last resort and it is
it is one of the last few lifeboats we
have
and we should use it and
by the way life votes are good i suspect
leonardo himself
would have used one on the titanic had
it been available
other critics worry about the moral
hazards of this technology
especially problematic is if companies
or governments
use the mere possibility of direct air
capture
as an excuse to postpone co2 emission
reductions
but let's be clear the pledge to remove
carbon dioxide in the future should not
be allowed
to embolden emitters today and this is
where we need
good policy i'm the first to admit
that engineering and building director
capture machines
my life's work is only but a small piece
of what is needed to undo decades of
reckless co2 emissions
but this is why i'm here today to ask
for your help
director capture needs you as well to
find the right policies
the right financial incentives and even
the right regulations
and while i cannot promise too much
glory
or applause at khan or otherwise
i can promise you it will be earth
changing
thank you